la parole est à monsieur ladislas
poniatowski pour le groupe union pour un
mouvement populaire
merci monsieur président monsieur le
ministre de l'éducation nationale un
grand ministre n'est pas forcément celui
qui dirige un grand ministère fût ce
celui de l'éducation nationale
un grand ministre est celui qu'il montre
qu'il sait écouter entendre les français
en depuis le début de votre réforme sur
les rythmes scolaires
vous avancez très sûr de vous mais vous
n'écoutez personnes vous n'écoutez pas
les enseignants qui sont en grève
aujourd'hui qu'ils ne veulent pas de
votre réforme
écoutez les monsieur le ministre le ce
sont des des enseignants sont des gens
compétents ils sont soucieux du devenir
de nos enfants ils ont des idées
pourquoi leur imposez vous une réforme
au lieu de les écouter au lieu de
dialoguer avec eux vous n'écoutez pas
plus les parents d'élèves les parents
d'élèves qui ne veulent pas de votre
réforme
vous n'écoutez même pas ceux qui sont
entrés dans votre réforme depuis le mois
de septembre dernier
ceux là sont en train de vous dire nos
enfants n'en peuvent plus ils sont en
train de vous dire se lever cinq jours
par semaine tôt ils partent et ils
rentrent épuisé monsieur milices
c'est dans 17% des communes que votre
réforme est entrée en application
pourquoi ne prenez-vous pas le temps de
tirer les leçons de ce qui s'est passé
dans ces 17% de communes monsieur le
ministre vous n'écoutez pas non plus des
élus vous n'écoutez pas les élus
qu'est-ce qu'il vous dise non mais ils
vous disent nous n'avons pas les moyens
sachez que une grande majorité d'entre
eux ne sont pas hostiles à votre réforme
ils disent nos budgets ne nous le
permettent pas ils disent n'est pas
simplement dans les communes rurales
même ailleurs
ils disent nous avons pas les locaux
pour organiser votre réforme ils disent
nous ne trouvons pas de personnel
compétent écoutez les monsieur le
ministre c'est il exprimait un
ras-le-bol
beaucoup d'entre nous nous sommes et
luge
on nous a réduit les datations de l'état
et c'est à ce moment là que vous voulez
charger encore un peu plus les communes
le gouvernement ne veut pas d'un côté
opposé du lioran si open est ce qu'ils
les communes les vos questions en disant
vous dépenser trop pour le personnel et
par ailleurs nous demandé d'embaucher
des animateurs en plus c'est ça qu'ils
expriment monsieur le ministre
donc écouter les entendez les nous vous
en donnons l'occasion nous avons le
groupe ump déposent une proposition de
loi qui vous permettra de répondre je
dirais calmement à toutes ces
inquiétudes main donc ma question
monsieur le ministre
quand c'est ce rêve ou d'être sourd à
tous ces messages qui vient de tous les
côtés je remercie merci la parole est à
monsieur le ministre de l'éducation
nationale monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur poniatowski
vous avez parfaitement raison il
convient d'entendre les uns et les
autres surtout sur un dossier aussi
important qui est celui de la réussite
scolaire des enfants de france et d'une
façon plus globale de leur réussite
éducative
c'est un sujet de préoccupation pour
nous tous
lorsque nous savons que 20 à 25 % de ces
enfants sont en difficulté que 150000
l'insee vient de le rappeler même un peu
plus sorte de notre système scolaire
sans qualification et que les inégalités
s'accroissent considérablement dans
notre pays au point que nous allons
apprendre sans doute bientôt que nous
somems les recordmans cela c'est le
résultat d'un certain nombre de choix le
choix d'abord de ne pas recruter un
nombre de professeurs suffisant le choix
ensuite de ne plus les formes et le
choix enfin malheureux et récent
d'enlever du temps scolaire et du temps
scolaire de qualité aux enfants de
france
ce choix à quatre ans le président de la
république le gouvernement ont décidé de
d'opérer le redressement de l'école
française de permettre à tous les
enfants leur réussite parce que ce sera
demain la réussite du pays
toutes les organisations internationales
nous le disent
cela suppose une action résolue de
l'état refaire les programmes embaucher
des professeurs les former à nouveau
passer au numérique avoir des
dispositifs pour ceux qui sont dans le
décrochage tout ça nous le faisons avec
un budget vous le savez nous en avons
discuté en commission au sénat cette
semaine qui est un budget prioritaire ma
préoccupation majeure c'est que les
élèves demain de ce pays
25% new delhi mme sellah puisse lire
écrire et compter lorsqu'il arrive en 6e
et à partir de là construire leur
autonomie leur insertion professionnelle
et même leur citoyenneté car vous
noterez qu'il ya une corrélation étroite
entre l'échec scolaire et les
comportements extrémistes dont nous
avons parlé
alors pour ce faire il faut donner aux
enfants un temps de qualité scolaire
tous les pays d'europe
nous sommes le seul à faire les quatre
jours tous les pays d'europe ont au
minimum l'allemagne que vous prenez
souvent en exemple cinq jours à 6 jours
au minimum cinq matinées de classe parce
que pour lire écrire compter
on apprend mieux à 9h30 le matin qu'à 16
heures en fin de journée
c'est ce que nous faisons et en même
temps nous luttons contre les inégalités
parce que lorsque les enfants sont pas à
l'école m
du matin ils sont en haut pour les plus
déshérités d'entre eux il ya de très
belles études ils sont devant la
télévision
il sauva des cages d'escalier ne sont
pas dans un dispositif éducatif
ce que nous mettons en route à côté du
meilleur temps scolaire c'est la
possibilité de passer de 20 pour son
enfant à 80% enfants accueillis dans des
dispositifs périscolaire et pour ce
faire nous avons besoin puisque c'est la
responsabilité des communes de les aider
nous avons parlé avec chacun les
intérêts des uns ne sont pas les
intérêts des autres
on le sait depuis longtemps dans ce pays
mais on ne construit pas un intérêt
général avec une addition d'intérêt
partie conclure mais ça c'est l'intérêt
des élèves
c'est l'intérêt de la france l'écouté là
il y à un comité de suivi
nous avons déjà proposé des aménagements
nous avons écouté les communes nous
avons différé le temps d'application
nous avons créé le fond et nous avons
laissé une liberté qui aujourd'hui fait
souvent problème et provoque chez les
enseignants une certaine colère nous
continuerons parce que nous savons que
nous agissons dans l'intérêt du pays et
nous essaierons de vous convaincre que
vous pouvez vous y associer merci